foreign
let's go out to Los Angeles the City of
Angels and talk to Justin what's up
Justin how we doing
hey Dr doley how's it going it's an
honor to be talking with you we're
partying man it's honor to talk to you
dude what's up
yeah so my situation
um
basically so ever since I was a kid ever
since I was little my dream was to uh
was to become an airline pilot
um and so I kind of pursued that dream
I went to college after college became a
commercial pilot and flight instructor
but then due to some medical and mental
health stuff I actually wasn't able to
continue past that and
um since really flying was my identity
it kind of put me in a rough spot for a
while really felt like I had kind of
lost my purpose
um and it's it's gotten better since
then I've been going I've had gone to
some counseling and I'm enjoying what
I'm doing now but it still pops up here
and there and I've I've kind of found
myself
um like whenever I drive by at an
airport I start feeling pretty low and
it feels like kind of I'm going back to
square around to square one so my guess
my question overall is how I can kind of
begin to fully Let It Go and move on and
embrace what's ahead yeah man thanks for
the call so um what put this picture in
your head as a kid just curious
yeah I I've thought about that it I mean
nobody in my family were pilots or
anything like that it was just something
that I've always kind of been into
everything that moves trains planes
boats and
um planes just caught my eye and that's
kind of what drew me toward it from a
young age yeah I was recently
sitting down with somebody and we were
kind of doing some
mining of of my past and
it occurred to me that my dad used to
really talk positive so my dad you know
was a hostage negotiator for the SWAT
team and
um there was a psychologist on staff
like a staff psychologist with the with
the police department that was kind of
over everything and my dad used to talk
about that guy with reverence
like we would be he'd say like we were
dealing with issue issue issue issue
we'd call and wake him up middle of the
night tell him he'd go just ask him this
and we'd always ask him and he would
just the guy was that was about to jump
would just come down or the guy who had
a bomb which would just walk out the
front door and so I had to wonder man I
always hear my dad talk about this one
guy with such reverence is that the tiny
Mustard Seed of you should be in mental
health and then your dad will think he's
your dad would be proud of you too and I
just wondered and so I always love to
ask that question where is that seed
especially from a young age
um
who in your life or what in your life
planted that seed but who knows what it
is right I just wondered if you were
like no my dad used to be a pilot or he
used to talk how amazing Pilots were or
my mom anyway my mom a pilot saved my
mom's life or anything
yeah no I haven't I haven't found
anything like that that I can think of
it was just more of the fact that I
loved airplanes and everything like that
so that's very cool all right so what's
the medical issue man what happened
yeah so it started with
um well it started I was flying one time
um just by myself I was building
building some hours for one of my
certificates and I'm just out of nowhere
really out of nowhere my my toes my
fingers all started going dangly and
numb
um and I started to kind of my vision
started to go away and I I really
thought like I was gonna black out and
that was going to be it right there
um and I remember yeah it was that was
just a that was the first instance of it
and so I thought it was carbon monoxide
poisoning from um from the airplane but
it turns out that was not the case I
went to see some doctors and some panic
attack that's that's what they had told
me that it most likely was yeah and so
those started coming back and I had a
whole bunch of those and I ended up
finishing the program successfully but
after that it was I was kind of left at
this Crossroads as like you know as as a
flight instructor my primary
responsibility is going to be to ensure
the safety of the whoever's in my
airplane and I can't do that right now
it's just not really going to be the
repeatable option so did you take
yourself out
uh yeah I did okay yeah
can I give you an alternative hypothesis
yeah absolutely there's the obvious loss
man you put your whole life into this
and you train for it you got certified
in it you had this vision of this life
you became an instructor right I mean
this was your world
but there's also another component when
your body betrays you
and that's the part underneath the job
that's the part underneath the identity
part where suddenly just walking on two
feet becomes unstable because the one
thing that you rely on every day failed
you in your eyes have failed you
yeah yeah
that to me is the core angst
because I don't trust me anymore if I
don't trust me I can't trust anybody
anything at all
yeah is that fair
yeah that's definitely fair so my
question for you would be what's the
core
anxiety underneath this because panic
attack is your body trying to get
basically a panic attack is your your
body's saying hey you haven't listened
to us we're out I quit
um yeah what's under what's the core
anxiety underneath that
yeah that's um
I don't know I mean yeah that's I think
that's the question I'm kind of seeking
answers for as well
uh because yeah it tends to
it's been a while since I've had one but
it always tend to happen when
not in places where I didn't feel in
control but in times where I felt that
if it happened then it would be in worst
case scenario so flying obviously is
when it would start to happen the most
and then driving would they would happen
pretty often too other than that it
would it never seemed to affect my life
in ways other than that I guess but
there's my guess is there's an
underlying so think of it this way you
have a cup like a glass
and it can take a lot
can take your gotta be at work on time
you got a wife it's that's hassling you
about something you got a kid that's got
the flu you've got Mom and Dad who are
telling you what you're doing for
Christmas it's got all these things in
in it's each one of them is putting like
um drops of water in this glass and it
fills up and up and up and you got that
car payment you got to make and you got
that soccer coach telling you that your
kid's gonna be the one but you're going
to have to have pay for private lessons
and you get this exam tomorrow for your
licensure all the stuff just keeps going
up and up and up
and then your glass is completely full
and then you get in a plane and you know
more so than the people in the plane
that you're super jittery and you didn't
sleep and you had 19 cups of coffee to
get the day going
and then the the Thought Machine kicks
up
and so what I want you to look at it is
not the about the Thought Machine that
thought machine is trying to keep you
safe
that panic attack is trying to keep you
I want to go underneath it and say what
in your life is filling up your glass so
tall
that when stress comes which I hope
honestly I hope my Pilots I have a lot
of flights coming up here I'll be
traveling a lot I hope all my Pilots are
a little bit angsty no I don't want them
to have anxiety disorders but I want
them all to be like hey we didn't do
this right I don't want them just
cruising man you know so I want you to
be like all right we're gonna focused
we're lasered in not like oh man you see
the game last night because in my head
that just means we're all gonna have
we're all gonna wreck and so my question
for you is
how's your underlying health
how's your underlying relationships
how is
um your underlying autonomy who who runs
your life
how's your marriage is these are
questions I want to get to the bottom of
because if you have an empty glass or a
glass that's very very
um small here's here's the story I love
to tell from stage
when my cousin died suddenly
like man it was awful and my wife and I
booked plane tickets and we got a hotel
in Houston we flew home
we were never anxious
man I was sad
I be but because my glass is empty most
of the time I don't owe anybody any
money I don't I work I see a counselor
regularly I work on my marriage really
hard I always try to be a better dad
like
because I'm not anxious when bad stuff
happens there's enough space in that
glass for me to accept whatever water
gets dumped into it
and my body doesn't shut us down because
it's prepared you see what you see the
analogy I'm getting at
yeah yeah
and maybe it's none of those things
I think more the the thought that I come
back to the most
I really think is the
is the idea that I'm like not where I
thought I would be
like I guess when it pops up I guess
when I when I see pictures of friends
that I was in flight school with who are
now making it to the Airlines and I feel
that sense of
um
I don't even really know how to describe
it but that's that's kind of I mean
that's where I see it the most it's just
jealousy and that's totally normal I'd
be jealous right
yeah
totally yeah
but I also think in the short term you
did a really Noble thing opting out
because you could have got through
flight school and got up in a plane and
no one would have known what you were
feeling in your shoes
Fair
yeah
yeah 100 no one would have known until
you blacked out and left that other
pilot all by himself
so for me the figuring out what is that
underlying anxiety about
because the trainers the certifiers the
instructors they believe in you
those who have ridden with you before
they believe in you your students have
believed in you the one thing that
doesn't believe in you is your body for
some reason
yeah and I'd want to get to the core of
that
the second piece on the alternative what
are you doing now
you're a non-profit and I'm also going
back to back to school what are you
doing there
that's a non-profit no no no going back
to school for what
I'm getting a master's in counseling ah
there you go okay so have you gone to
your own therapy
yeah yeah I have yeah you all haven't
got to the bottom of the anxiety
yeah I
it doesn't yeah I guess it doesn't seem
like we have
uh I yeah
come on counselors
I
yeah come on counselors
um
I guess I thought I was I thought yeah I
guess I thought it was
farther past this than I'm
realizing now just I guess with things
that keep popping up so when people get
cancer
when people end up with a brain tumor
when people
um who are star athletes blow their knee
out
there is a it's different than a Formula
One driver whose car wrecks on them
because they there's a gap between that
car and them
when your body fails you
it's devastating
because if I can't again because if I
can't rely on my body good God man and
there's always a coming back around that
after the next five years we are gonna
go to the doctor and see if we're cancer
if cancer is still undetectable
is it undetectable is it undetectable
and there's that apprehension there's
that that
um anxiousness and that's good that's
right
because your body let you down
in in this in this analogy right I don't
think globally it lets you down but
um the picture you had was we're gonna
do this thing and your body's like we're
not gonna do that
and so I think there is a there will be
some it will take time to make peace
with
that's not for me
or in this season that wasn't for me
are you done flying forever can you
never do it again
yeah I
I think probably I it's hard to answer
at this point but yeah I think so
why
I mean
I mean unless I can get to a point where
I know for a certain I could do it
safely I wouldn't want to you can only
do that in the air
yeah yeah exactly
and is the thought of getting back up in
the air just terrify you just get that
warm feeling in your guts
yeah and it it really did ever since
because when that when it first happened
that was still months away from when I
was finished and so really ever since
that ever since that day getting back in
there
um was pretty tough and and that you've
not that was when I had somebody else
with me
um and so going back by my by myself I
just I don't know how I just don't know
how my body would react to that all
right here's what I want you to do and
if your therapist can't do this I want
you to find somebody in your local
community who can do this and out there
in California I promise you can find
this
I want somebody to do either EMDR or
somebody to do some sort of Bodywork
with you
and body work is sometimes they hold
your hand they put their hand on your
shoulder they put your hand on your back
your head while you are laying down
while you're sitting down while you tell
what happened
and you're you process those feelings as
though they have as they happened again
but you do it in the safety of somebody
else's space
okay okay and what it does is it
eventually discharges that that trauma
that's held in your body
and it might be an overuse of the word
but feeling like your body failed you is
a core trauma trauma means I'm separate
from myself
and feeling like I can't take this step
because my knee is going to blow out on
me again feeling like I can't do
something hard because last time I did
my body almost shut me down in the like
30 000 feet in the air
is that's that's thick that's the trauma
right and every time you think about it
your body remembers the past and it
drags it into the present
and so we have to unhook our response
from that you weren't safe then you're
you're great now
now let's figure out what that is and
dude it's okay to be jealous it's okay
to be like ah they did it I didn't
that's okay you're not broken or crazy
you need to grieve that
I would love to see you take some
autonom I mean some ownership some
autonomy so um not autonomy that's the
wrong word I want you to take some
ownership here's what this is I want you
to write Justin the pilot a letter
and I want you to say Dear Justin the
pilot
we were supposed to be flying today
and be very specific and
I chose to not fly
I chose a different life path I chose
health and healing I chose fill in the
blank
and I want you to begin to not
be subjected to a body that you don't
trust I want you to take ownership of
that body again
in a weird way anxiety tends to follow
the leader
and if the leader is firm and committed
in taking ownership anxiety says we
don't have to ring the alarms because
that guy's driving
it's when your body thinks dude he's not
paying attention he's not paying
attention then it will start shutting
you down
see what I'm saying
yeah absolutely because I think there's
a lot of grieving you haven't done yet I
think you may have talked with a
counselor for a while and y'all just
talked and how does that make you feel
and how's that make you feel but let's
get in and do the hard work which is
we're going to grieve this thing I'm
gonna take ownership of it because you
aren't kicked out
your body said we're out and then you
did a noble thing and you walked away
and so you made a choice and now you're
making a choice to go be a mental health
counselor which is awesome we need some
more great counselors out there and
you're going to make a choice to get to
the core anxiety and you're going to
make a choice to release your body from
responding to this nonsense every time
you think about a pilot or every time
you see a plane fly over every time
you're about to get on a plane and your
body goes whoosh and drops and that that
slow motion feeling we're gonna be done
with that now
I'm gonna go process I'm gonna go back
to that feeling back to that moment and
I'm gonna free my body from it and by
the way we're gonna get to what in the
world is my body so scared of
I landed the plane the teacher said I
did great my schooling said I did great
they certified me everything why is my
body so scared of and my guess is you're
going to find something in your
environment that's much much bigger
somebody who didn't believe in you for a
long period of time and cast a narrative
into you that became part of your
nervous system or you're lonely or you
don't take care of your body or any
number of things
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of building a non-anxious life as
well I want you to read that book and
see if any of that Rings true
but my guess is there's a deeper well
here's a deeper picture
and I don't want to put um I don't want
to put hope where
you have put something to bed but
man you get to this core anxiety
and maybe you're back up there flying
again
or maybe
you deal with that core anxiety and a
couple years from now in your licensed
counselor you're sitting across the the
room from somebody
and you're able to look into their eyes
and say I've been there too
I've been there too
I'm pretty man you did a hard hard thing
you have a hard
um road to go into the future and you
can do it you can do it